if you were the fed what do you do
oh if i'm the fed i send the economy
into recession gain some credibility and
set us up for a good 2023. you just this
is this year's awash you just throw in
the flag well it's not even thrown in
the flag it's punting i mean you're
football you're a football guy it's like
it's playing you're punting you're this
is the fed is if they don't like you
there's two choices you can be uh what's
my man in san diego uh who always goes
up forward in fourth down you can be
that guy and out of the playoffs or you
can punt the ball and and you know live
to fight another day and i think punting
the ball equates to you know engineering
and slowdown in the economy and it's not
just our economy the fed can take crude
oil from 130 dollars a barrel to 65 a
barrel overnight if it wanted to
take the policy rate up 500 basis points
and see what happens they don't want to
do that obviously they don't want big
changes because big changes tend to
scare people and you get all these side
effects as it relates to um you know
credit intermediation
all you know the hypoth there's a lot of
side effects in the financial plumbing
of it all so what what do they end up
doing they just raise interest rates to
like
they're going to try to 300 300 basis
points i think
yeah no they're i don't think they're
going to get that far
the problem is again we the the fed is
starting this tightening process
too late in the business cycle well to
be clear we're at eight percent cpi they
haven't raised rates at all and they
were literally buying assets like two
weeks ago like two weeks ago yeah i know
these guys are doing qe like two weeks
ago dude
yeah it's funny
the fed did qe for nine months while
inflation was above five percent i know
what wouldn't i'm sure i'll write a book
at some point that's a great question
somebody should find that one off that's
a freebie for somebody out there
the start of my book would be yeah and
the fed was buying bonds like two weeks
you know like two weeks ahead of this
like so yeah no my point is so they're
going to try to walk a fine line right
the fed doesn't want to spook anybody
they certainly don't want to um upset
what's priced into markets from a policy
tightening standpoint so they're going
to do the 25 basis points maybe they'll
talk up if hey if russia ukraine goes
well we'll do 50 basis points in may or
we'll do 50 basis points in june but the
reality is as long as inflation momentum
stays elevated
the probability that that 50 basis
points in may
gets solidified and then 50 basis points
in june that gets solidified those
probabilities start to go up and so it's
increasingly looking like the fed might
have to front load a lot of tightening
as a function of being so behind the
curve on inflation so behind the curve
as it relates to the economy this is the
lowest the unemployment rate's ever been
prior to the fed lifting uh interest
rates ever in the history of the fed
funds rate
and so you know there's a there's you
know there's a saying on wall street
that the fed you know tends to cause an
accident when it when it tightens policy
it usually tightens until it breaks
something now it breaks something in
financial markets or breaks something in
in the real economy
the fed is definitely going to break
something because the probability of
them breaking something is as high as
it's ever been because they're so late
in this process you know imagine like um
why why did we get here like why didn't
they do something earlier because they
arrogance no well
there's a couple reasons i think i'm so
glad you said arrogance and and uh you
know certain myself as a professional
forecaster i think i would consider
myself and everybody who does this for a
living we all need to eat a little bit
of humble pie nobody got this inflation
call right maybe with exception i think
jim bianco i don't think he had forecast
but he certainly um
he had a view that inflation would be
stickier and persistent i remember that
back in the summer where a lot of folks
didn't uh but generally speaking nobody
nobody sought 7.9 inflation six nine
months ago nobody saw five percent
inflation nine twelve months ago you
know so the reality is we all got this
wrong but the problem is we're not set
in policy you know the fed is setting
policy on its forecasts which are
obviously wrong by a double and so
that's a problem so arrogance is a
factor in terms of transitory but the
real factor of why they're so late
is because they made themselves that
they chose to be late go back to the
fall of 2020 when they change their um
their inflation target their inflation
mandate basically to an average
inflation targeting scheme which means
instead of saying two percent is the
ceiling on inflation we're comfortable
having inflation average two percent uh
the core pc specifically so they changed
that and the reason they changed that
was the real change that matters they
you know they kind of adopted awoke
framework to be quite frank you know
this this sort of this concept of
maximum and inclusive employment um
really stem from you know kind of the
wake of the george ford protest all this
stuff and the fed realized after having
done a lot of research and this
something i've been talking about my
whole career which is the fed always
takes the punch bowl away when you know
the economy starts getting good for
disaffected groups african-americans to
hispanics you know those are typically
you know those people typically have
higher unemployment rates they they the
their unemployment rates go down usually
after you know whites and this is and
asians and stuff like that so i think
the fed
wanted to do something to address the
kind of zeitgeist of america back in
that in that particular time frame and
they what they said was hey look we're
going to ease policy until we see the
whites of the eyes of of the lowest
unemployment rate ever for these
particular groups and they actually did
that and they did that and they made a
lot of real substantial progress in q4
in particular for females for the you
know for folks without high school
diplomas all this stuff and so they got
what they wanted but the problem is they
had to keep easing and go crazy and go
ham with balance sheet and zero percent
interest rates to get that done and now
we're dealing with the consequences hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time